Transcriptor: Paul Alduncin
Revisor: Anna Sobota
Me gustaría convenceros que todos
somos líderes que cruzan barreras.
Para ello, podríamos abrir las luces
y podíamos observarnos.
Nos daríamos unos minutos para charlar
y encontraríamos que, tal vez, somos
más buenos en encontrar diferencias
que en encontrar en qué
somos todos iguales.
Seguramente nos fijaríamos en que
las orejas no son iguales,
ni el pelo, ni el color.
Que a lo mejor tampoco tenemos
los mismos hobbies o la profesión.
Somos muy buenos encontrando diferencias,
pero yo os diré en qué somos comunes.
Somos comunes aunque, a veces,
nos veamos en 2D o en 3D.
Todos y cada uno de
nosotros somos seres en 3D.
Aunque a menudo en el último año
nos hemos visto más en 2D que en 3D.
Para sacar el máximo potencial
de esas dimensiones de las personas,
necesitamos líderes
que sean capaces  de ir más allá.
De ver las personas en 3D.
De sacar su máximo potencial aunque
sea a través de una pantalla.
La empatía será
una herramienta muy potente
para encontrar esas otras dimensiones.
De hecho, yo no me imagino un líder
que no sea empático.
Empático para conocer las soluciones
a los problemas que intentamos resolver
viendo el problema
desde diferentes puntos de vista.
Solo de esa forma conseguiremos
una solución casi mágica.
Empático con su equipo, sus dificultades,
sus fortalezas y sus debilidades.
Sacando el máximo potencial
a esa realidad 3D de su equipo.
Será la empatía esa herramienta mágica
y es el líder que
conseguirá cruzar barreras.
Soy Meritxell Teixidó.
Me gusta describirme como un líder 3D
al que le encanta cruzar barreras
y hacerlo con empatía.
Apasionada por la ciencia desde
muy pequeña
y también por el arte.
He tenido el privilegio de dedicarme
a la ciencia desde muchos puntos de vista,
pero también, a menudo, saltando barreras.
Saltando la barrera de la academia
a la creación de mi propia empresa
biotecnológica en julio de 2020,
en la primera ola de la pandemia.
Cruzando barreras para llevar
los fármacos y crear una tecnología
que permitiera llevar
los fármacos hasta el cerebro.
Así poder dar una mejor oportunidad
a todos aquellos
que sufrimos o sufriremos
una enfermedad del cerebro.
¿Y por qué no?
Cruzando, rompiendo barreras y
estereotipos de ser la mamá especial
de un niño especial
al que le encanta viajar.
El hombre ha dedicado siglos y siglos
a crear o construir murallas y barreras.
Tal vez descubriríamos que somos mejores
creando barreras que destruyéndolas.
La Muralla China, la ciudad de
Carcassonne o la Muralla de Ávila,
todas tienen una misma función:
protegernos.
Controlar qué es lo que entra
o lo que sale de un lugar.
De hecho, en nuestro propio organismo
existen muchas barreras.
Barreras que tienen la misma función:
la barrera de la retina que protege
el ojo, la barrera intestinal,
la barrera placentaria, la piel o
la barrera hematoencefálica.
Podríamos seguir durante un largo periodo
de tiempo encontrando barreras
que protegen nuestro organismo.
Tienen la misma función de proteger
lo que entra y que sale de ese tejido.
Pero también nos dificulta
cuando tenemos de llegar allí.
Hace 15 años, después de 15 años
en un centro de investigación,
dirigiendo 10 tesis doctorales,
publicando más de 50 artículos
y la coautora de 5 patentes
decidí que tenía un sueño:
llevar toda aquella tecnología,
que había sido un esfuerzo de equipo,
más cerca de los pacientes
para dar una oportunidad
de la mejora de ese transporte.
Para eso tuve que cruzar barreras.
Las barreras biológicas como las que
os explicaba tendremos que cruzar,
pero también las barreras
de falta de inversión
en investigación en pediatría.
Y por qué no, las barreras
para conseguir un día a la salud
para todos en todo el planeta.
Su importancia la hemos descubierto
probablemente desde
el inicio de la pandemia.
Antes de cruzar barreras,
me gustaría saber por qué
el cerebro está protegido.
¿Para dificultarnos la vida?
No, porque probablemente es el órgano
más preciado de nuestro cuerpo.
Es aquel ordenador central
con el que nacemos.
Nos ayuda a crecer, disfrutando
y aprendiendo de nuestro entorno.
Pero de esta forma como está protegido,
también nos pasa que,
cuando lo tengamos de tratar,
esa protección nos dificultará la llegada.
Esa protección actuará como
esa muralla de la ciudad medieval.
Lo protege.
Perfecto, lo tenemos ahí.
Pero, ¿qué pasa cuando
necesitamos tratarlo?
La pregunta es muy básica.
Uno de cada cuatro de nosotros
necesita el tratamiento del cerebro
durante nuestra vida.
Este número parece muy grande.
Es que lo es.
¿Por qué?
Porque empezaríamos a sumar
y empezaríamos una lista:
Alzheimer, Parkinson,
esquizofrenia, depresión.
Y seguiríamos y seguiríamos.
Un montón de enfermedades minoritarias
que sumarían que
uno de cada cuatro de nosotros
durante nuestra vida necesita
tratar el ordenador central.
La dificultad viene de llegar allí.
Hay fármacos muy prometedores
para esas enfermedades.
Pero, ¿cómo está protegido el cerebro?
¿Por qué es difícil llegar allí?
Es muy fácil.
Los capilares de nuestro cuerpo
es como si fueran tuberías.
Esas tuberías, si las miráramos,
estarían formadas por células
que serían como
los ladrillos de esa pared.
Para ir del torrente sanguíneo
a cualquier tejido,
podríamos pasar por el espacio
entre los ladrillos de esa pared.
En el caso del cerebro, esos ladrillos
están estrechamente unidos
de forma que para entrar al cerebro
necesitamos entrar al ladrillo de la pared
y salir al otro lado.
Eso es de gran dificultad.
Pero el cerebro no puede estar
completamente aislado.
Se calcula que duraríamos menos de media
hora si estuviera completamente aislado.
El cerebro es el gran consumidor
de nutrientes
y también tiene que sacar todos
los residuos que lo podrían estropear.
De forma que esa muralla tiene puertas,
igual que las puertas
de las ciudades amuralladas.
Por esas puertas, normalmente,
es por donde entrarán los nutrientes
y saldrán los residuos.
Nuestra idea fue entrar
por ahí los fármacos
que por sí solos no saben llegar.
Para hacerlo hicimos lo siguiente.
Teníamos un montón de fármacos
que no descubrimos nosotros,
pero sí los científicos
de todo el mundo.
Fármacos prometedores
para la esquizofrenia.
para los tumores cerebrales.
Pero les falta el transporte.
Esos fármacos, lo que nosotros
hemos hecho, es unirles una llave.
¿Y cuál será esa llave?
Esa llave será un péptido que no es
más que una proteína muy pequeña.
Esa proteína será una llave
que cruzará esa barrera
y llevará a modo de llavero un fármaco
que por sí solo no sabía
ir a ningún sitio.
Volviendo a mi pasión por viajar.
¿Qué creéis que tienen en común
todos los animales venenosos?
Todos estos animales que podemos
encontrar en nuestro planeta
tienen una cosa en común.
Todos ellos tienen venenos
que están formados por miles,
sino millones de péptidos.
Muchos de ellos saben
actuar a nivel cerebral,
el sistema nervioso central diríamos,
con lo cual tienen
esa habilidad, esa llave.
Después de muchos años,
los científicos estuvimos estudiando
cómo eran esos péptidos,
por qué sabían llegar al cerebro.
De ahí, descubrir péptidos llave.
En nuestro caso,
un péptido inspirado en un péptido
que encontramos en el veneno de abeja.
Esa llave mágica se crea con la que
hicimos un experimento apasionante.
Conseguimos hacer llegar al cerebro
in vivo, viéndolo además en directo,
unas nanopartículas:
unas bolitas pequeñas en tamaño
nanométrico que eran fluorescentes.
Gracias a las llaves las veíamos
llegar al parénquima cerebral.
Vamos, el terreno donde
viven las neuronas.
La descubierta de las llaves fue
un ejercicio de prueba y error.
Un ejercicio de creatividad, de equipo.
Pero la creatividad
también tiene barreras.
Pero yo os confesaré: hay
una herramienta muy potente
para cruzar esas barreras
de la que creatividad.
Se dice o se llama
crear equipos 3D.
Que aporten soluciones muy diferentes.
Que tengan capacidades y discapacidades
que les permitan ver los problemas
y las soluciones desde un 360 grados.
Esos equipos son los que
no tendrán límites,
los que considerarán soluciones
innovadoras, empáticas e inclusivas.
Porque no olvidemos, ningún proyecto
tiene sentido si no tiene alma.
Si no está creado con empatía
y si no quiere cambiar el mundo.
Como dijo Mahatma Gandhi:
“Sé el cambio que
quieres ver en el mundo”.
Y yo añado, hazlo con empatía.
Volviendo a nuestra visión inicial de ver
en que somos diferentes y somos iguales:
creemos equipos muy variados,
equipos con todo tipo de diversidad.
Es donde encontraremos
las mejores soluciones:
innovadoras, creativas,
inclusivas, mágicas.
No olvidemos que, todos
y cada uno de nosotros,
somos líderes en 3D
que están aprendiendo a cruzar barreras.
Gracias.